I grew up just absolutely loving movies
my first movie that my dad took me to
was a UT and I had a popcorn bucket like
up to here I could barely see over it
really the thing that got me into visual
effects is how it is a blend of artistry
and technology we create an illusion
that transports people into a different
place
2010 we created atomic fiction which is
a visual effects and animation studio
one of the most challenging parts of
doing visual effects is called rendering
that process can take anywhere between 2
minutes and 40 hours for every single
frame every twenty-fourth of a second of
a film rendering takes an immense amount
of computing horsepower using Google
cloud platform to do our rendering we
have massive infrastructure off-site
when we need it and then nothing when we
don't it allows us to use computers for
minutes at a time and only get billed
for what we use and so we took that as
an opportunity to create our own toolset
more specific to our industry called
conductor which runs on top of Google's
cloud platform it helped us put the
resources on where it was important the
artists and making sure that every penny
that our client spent made it up on the
screen these movies that might have
otherwise been bottled up in a
filmmakers mind are now actually seeing
the light of day on the movie screen
there's no greater satisfaction than
creating a visual effect that people
just believe that there's somewhere else
that's what we do is we create fiction
hopefully it's just the most believable
fiction that you can imagine